the head of the United Nations has taken
the world's major economies to task for
failing to reduce carbon emissions
warning that the point of no return is
fast approaching Antonio Guterres says
the global push to stop climate change
has been utterly inadequate he was
speaking as a two-week international
climate summit gets underway in Madrid
here's more of what he had to say we are
in a deep hole and we are still digging
soon it will be too deep to escape I
welcome the voices of the young
activists I've been meetings they
understand that we are jeopardizing
their future that is why I will continue
to push every day to keep climate at the
top of the international agenda Antonio
Guterres there well many parts of the
world are of course already feeling the
effects of climate change the Seychelles
for example is an island chain in the
Indian Ocean is threatened by rising sea
levels and the destruction of local
marine life but this low-lying nation
with its capital city of Victoria is
enacting policies at hopes will serve as
an example for others
over 300,000 people a year head to the
Seychelles to enjoy a holiday in
paradise the vast array of corals fish
and other marine life in the surrounding
ocean is breathtaking but this entire
ecosystem is under threat from climate
change the president of the Seychelles
called for urgent action when he took in
the ocean floor earlier this year in a
submersible vehicle scientists have
spoken and politicians around the world
the time has come for us to act I will
be a strong ambassador in a strong
advocate for marine protection around
the world the most alarming problem for
the Seychelles waters is rising
temperatures warmer seas have bleached
many of the coral reefs damaging areas
of natural beauty for a country that
relies on its fishing and tourism
industries the impending disaster could
cost many people their jobs we are the
least responsible for the problems of
climate change yet we are vulnerable in
fact if we were different the fight
would have been different the Seychelles
is working on a solution a government
led initiative is turning one third of
the country's territorial waters an area
the size of Germany into protected zones
these zones stretching out from the
country's inner islands and Aldabra
group Islands aim to limit human
activity and thus make marine life more
resilient marine scientists from the
University of Oxford and the Nexen
Institute have been examining the
Seychelles waters there was a credible
diversity and abundance of fish
especially in protected areas like
Aldabra which shows that marine
protected areas do work when they are
put in place the Seychelles is aiming to
become a model for marine protection
around the world in an effort to slow
the effects of climate change its
president is hoping other countries will
take notice we all know that we have a
problem what is needed
is responsible global action and there
is no there's no time for blame game the
Seychelles and its president are already
seeing the effects of climate change
they don't want discussion they want
action now well will they see it let's
talk about that more now with DW science
and environment reporter Louis Osborn
good morning Louise the UN
secretary-general they are saying is
issuing a dire warning the planet a
protein the point of no return is is
there an expectation that this
conference can can turn things around
well it's difficult to say whether it
will turn it around completely the motto
for the conference this year is time for
action but really they're not quite
ready for that yet they're still trying
to finish the rulebook which is
something they should have completed
last year in Katowice but that they just
were unable to agree on the last article
which is article 6 and deals with carbon
markets so that's what they're going to
be concentrating on this year another
thing that they have to worry about is
their ambitions so the National targets
that each country has made to reduce
carbon emissions if they keep going
along that road and follow those targets
they won't be able to keep the
temperature below 2 degrees Celsius
which is what the Paris agreement calls
for it will be at least 3 degrees
Celsius so that's something else that
they have to talk about to try to turn
things around
okay now Guterres pointed to China as
being a major offender it's the biggest
producer 27% of the world's carbon
emissions some it is it one of the
countries that's that's not on target
with the carbon markets that you
mentioned actually that's not the case
that is on target it's one of the only
countries in the you know one of the
higher emitting countries that's on
target to to reach its goals the problem
is that the goals like I said are just
too low so even if China does get there
it's not going to make enough of a
difference for temperatures to remain
lower there's also the issue of you know
emissions that are being made elsewhere
by Chinese companies so for example in
Afric
where they're building power plants and
things like that and and that is another
contribution of China to global carbon
emissions just not done in in China
itself so we were looking to Seychelles
there's taking a role model position
what needs to be done quickly to halt
global warming I mean we're sitting in
every year and the forest fires in
Australia rising temperatures sea levels
what can be done to halt it quickly well
what really would need to be done with B
for countries to simply cut their carbon
emissions obviously that's not something
that they're going to do straightaway
phase-out of coal needs to be done very
quickly environmentalists have been
calling that they actually worried that
the market carbon market issue that's
going to be discussed this year will
actually detract from just taking direct
action and phasing out coal and and
cutting carbon emissions through
transport these kinds of things
governments are still working out a way
to to do this but they obviously need to
do it more quickly um climate protests
have been intensifying over the past
year we've been reporting extensively on
that the Friday's for future movement
for example what effects are these
protests having on policymakers meeting
in Madrid well I think governments are
starting to feel the strain of having so
many protests taking place I mean in
September millions of people took to the
streets for the global climate strike on
Friday it was hundreds of thousands of
people so governments are starting to
feel the pressure of that like I said
before they really need to work on their
ambitions and that is what protesters
are calling for glitter toon Berg will
be there this week she's expected to
arrive from her Atlantic trip tomorrow
in Portugal and then I guess you'll make
her way very quickly to Madrid she'll be
talking again to leaders and I am sure
that we can expect a speech that will
you know kind of match what she said in
New York so there will be bad okay so
she's very much a focal point for public
opinion right now okay Luis thanks so
very much for coming in on us